Good evening Valerie ayée,
good evening.
I have the job.
Forgive me,
but please,
thank you for accepting your invitation.
You are an MEP.
You have been designated today
head of the list of the renaissance party,
the party of Emmanuel Macron,
for the European elections.
It is the next nine/06.
The French don't know you,
not yet.
Uh.
Who are you?
And why are you? You?
First,
I would like to thank you for your invitation.
It's not every day
that we have the opportunity to address,
uh. Like this, to the French.
Hmm. So,
thank you.
Who I am, uh.
I am Valerie.
Here you go.
Thank you for pronouncing my last name.
I am 37 years old,
I come from Mayenne.
I am lucky to have grown up
in 1 farm with my sister and my brother.
My parents were farmers.
I got involved in political life at a very young age
since I became a consultant
municipal of my village
at the age of twenty-one.
In two thousand ten seven,
I joined Emmanuel Macron.
In two thousand nineteen,
I had the chance to become an MEP.
I have worked a lot since in the European Parliament
and I'm today,
uh.
Chairman of the Central Group
in the European Parliament.
This is the group of moderates of Emmanuel Macron.